are you worried about nuclear war
the possibility
of nuclear war
i think it's necessary to pay attention
to that possibility
that possibility existed before
the february 2022 full-blown invasion of
ukraine
the doomsday arsenal that russia
possesses is enough to destroy the world
many times over
and that's been the case every year
since the collapse of the soviet union
in 1991
and so of course we're concerned about
that
we do know however alex that they have a
system known as dual key
dual key for their strategic nuclear
weapons
strategic nuclear weapons means the ones
fired from silos the missiles
the ones delivered from bombers or the
ones fired from submarines right and
they're ready to go they're
intercontinental
we watch that very very closely
we watch all the movement of that and
the alerts
etc we have tremendously
let's say
tremendous inside intelligence on that
but dual key means that president putin
alone cannot fire them
he has one key which he must insert he
must then
insert the codes for a command to launch
that then goes to the head of the
general staff
who must has his own key and separate
codes and must do the same insert that
key in codes for them to launch
and so
will the general staff chief
go along
with the destruction of the world over a
battlefield loss in ukraine
i don't know the answer to that and i
don't know if anybody knows the answer
to that will those people flying those
bombers
if they get the order from if the dual
key system goes into action
and both keys are used and all the codes
are are implemented will those
young guys fly in those bombers let
those bombs go
will those at the missile silos
decide to engage and fire
we don't know but you can see that it's
more than one man making a decision here
in a system of strategic nuclear weapons
as far as the tactical
the so-called low yield or battlefield
nuclear weapons
we're not sure the system that they have
in russia these days for their implement
for their use of such tactical nuclear
weapons
it could well be that
that putin and just
himself
he alone can fire them or order them be
fired
but you know lex there's no tactical
nuclear weapon fired at ukraine that's
not also fired simultaneously at russia
if the kremlin is 600 miles from ukraine
and if the wind changes direction
or the wind happens to be blowing east
northeast
the fallout hits your kremlin
not just ukraine
moreover you have all those border
regions which are staging regions for
the russian offensive
and they're a lot closer than 600 miles
they're actually right there
and so you fire that weapon on ukrainian
territory and you can get the fallout
just like the chernobyl fallout
spread to sweden
which is how the
we got the kremlin 2 finally first they
denied they said oh we don't know why
there's a big nuclear cloud over sweden
we don't know where that came from but
eventually they admitted it
so russia can't actually use a nuclear
weapon
tactical battlefield one in ukraine
without also firing it at itself
and in addition it's that same dynamic i
alluded to earlier
which is to say
you bomb a hospital you bomb a school
there's more heavy weapons
going to ukraine from the west you can't
get away with any of the
there's always going to be a response
that's either proportional or greater
than proportional you could well have
europe
signing on to nato direct engagement
both washington oh boy and brussels
direct engagement of the russian army on
the territory of ukraine
you think that's possible to do that
without
dramatic escalation from the russian
side
yes i do think it's possible but it's
very worrisome just like you're saying
but but
if putin were to escalate like that
he's firing that weapon at
and he's potentially provoking a direct
clash with nato's military not just with
the ukrainian military
if you're sitting in the kremlin looking
at those charts likes
of nato capabilities
and you can't conquer ukraine which
didn't really have heavy weapons before
february 2022 at scale
and you're thinking okay now i'm gonna
take our nato
that would be a bold step
on the part of a russian leader and and
and let's also remember lex that there's
another variable here
you're a desperate as long as everyone
implements your orders
and so if people start to say
quietly not necessarily publicly i may
not implement that order
because that's maybe a criminal order or
my grandma is ukrainian or my wife is
ukrainian
or i don't want to go to the hog
i don't want to spend the rest of my
life in the hog or whatever it might be
at any point along the chain of command
from the general staff all the way down
right to the platoon
you're a desperate provided they
implement your orders
but who's to say
that somewhere along the chain of
command
people start to say you know
i'm going to ignore that order
or i'm going to sabotage that order or
i'm going to flee
the battlefield or i'm going to injure
myself
so that i don't have to fight or i'm
going to join the ukrainian side
and so it could be that's what's left of
the russian army in the field
begins to disintegrate
even if the ukrainians are not able to
mount that counter-offensive at scale
that combined arms operation
the russian military in the field which
has taken horrendous casualties as far
as we understand something like a third
of the original force
so you're talking about 50 to 60 000
that includes both dead and wounded to
the point of being unable to return to
the battlefield
those are big numbers those were a lot
of families
a lot of families affected
their sons or their their husbands or
their fathers are either missing an
action or the regime won't tell them
that they're dead
as you know from the sinking of that
flagship
uh moskva
right by the ukrainians
and so a disintegration of the russian
military because there are orders that
they either can't implement or don't
want to implement
is also not excluded and so you have
these two big variables the ukrainian
army in the field and its ability to
move from defense to offense at scale
and we're going to test that soon
and then the russian ability in the
field to hold together
in a war of conquest and aggression
where their
their conscripts or their fed dog food
or or or they don't have any weapons
anymore because there's no resupply and
so so the disintegration of the army
can't be excluded and then of course all
bets are off on the putin regime
more long term
there are these technology export
controls
we were talking about how the
military-industrial complex in russia is
dependent
on foreign component parts and software
and so if you have export controls
and you have firms voluntarily even when
they don't fall under export controls
leaving russian business refusing to do
business with russia
and we see this not just in the civilian
sector like with mcdonald's or many
other companies
we see this in the key
areas like the oil industry
with the executives
that is the western executives fleeing
giving up their positions
so russia's ability to resupply its
tanks resupply its missiles
resupply
its uniforms
resupply its food to its soldiers in the
field and then their boots
we see a lot of stuff under tremendous
stress and in the long term there's no
obvious way
they can rebuild the military-industrial
complex to produce those weapons
because they're reliant on foreign parts
that they can't get anymore and there
are no domestic substitutes
on the immediate horizon
that's
at the earliest a two-year
proposition to have domestic substitutes
and for some things like
microelectronics
they've never had domestic substitutes
going back to the soviet times as you
know well
and so there's that pressure
on russia from the technology export
controls
which if you're in
the security ministry or the defense
ministry if you're in that side of the
of the regime
you're feeling that pain as we speak
and you're wondering about the strategy
you